welcome everyone thanks for joining us
today for one of our first live sessions
in quite some time but I'm excited to do
it and those of you who've come to our
other live sessions probably have
noticed that this background is
different from the one that I had for
all those dark days of the virus where
outside my window was the uh
the lonely outskirts of Upstate New York
here I am back in my office at Columbia
University and it's kind of an
interesting thing I don't know how many
of you have seen Oppenheimer by now but
a little known fact well a well-known
fact to physicist but to those walking
in the streets of Upper Manhattan a
little known fact is that this building
where I'm sitting right now pene physics
Hall Columbia University was actually
where some of the work on the atomic
bomb took place the early work Leo
salard and en Rico firery and the the
these were the early days of trying to
determine the details about radioactive
decay and of course the key question
that people were interested in was
whether or not you could get a chain
reaction that would require the
radioactive decay to give off more
neutrons than were required to stimulate
that decay
because after all if one Neutron gets
you two well we all know what happens
from there two gets you four gets you
eight and so forth but if one gets you
one one times one doesn't take you very
far toward the kind of exponential
growth required for the possibility of a
chain reaction and
indeed it was Leo salard as some of you
may know the history who recognized that
this idea of radioactive decay and the
Chain Reaction could indeed give rise to
a powerful weapon
and
he drove out from here in Upper
Manhattan to see Albert Einstein in Long
Island 1939 I think it was to convince
Einstein to write Roosevelt that letter
that convinced Roosevelt the need to try
to make use of these ideas before
anybody else in the world got there
first so a lot of history in this
building right here and happy to talk a
little bit about that if that's where
the conversation I'm about to have with
Sean Carol should take us but you all
should feel free to send in any
questions that you have I don't have a
whole lot planned because Shan and I
have such common interest that there's
kind of almost no subject in science at
least where Sean and I don't have a
similar resonant passion perhaps that's
the way of saying it whether it's
quantum mechanics or the arrow of time
or cosmology or the measurement problem
we uh always seem to find ourselves in a
place whenever we get together of shared
interest so anything that you ask that
resonates with one of us will likely
resonate with both of us so feel free to
send your questions in and we have
someone monitoring the chat right now to
try to pull out those that seem the most
relevant to the conversation we're going
to have before I bring shown in let me
just quickly note what you just saw in
that little introductory sequence we are
having our first Live Events world
Science Festival that is in New York
City since before the pandemic right I
mean 2020 we were and root to having the
2020 World Science Festival when of
course everything shut down and we've
not gone live in New York City since
then we have gone live other parts of
the world those of you who are in
Australia know that we do World Science
Festival of Brisbane and we've done that
a few times now since the dark days of
the pandemic but we're not doing doing a
full Festival but we are doing what we
call science in September we're doing
seven events seven kind of intense
events that are spanning artificial
intelligence cosmology quantum
mechanics issues of new ideas of
cosmology that perhaps are competitors
at least in the minds of some to the
inflationary Theory Sean and I know that
will talk a little bit about that in
just a moment Sean and I are doing a
program with Carlo Rell and Elise crw on
issues in quantum mechanics at September
23rd at I think it's 4M so if you find
yourself in New York City September 21
to 24 please join us for those live
events in New York City but otherwise at
some point you'll be able to see most of
them as we will put them out into the
world at some point through uh the usual
digital means that we've been doing for
the last few years all right with that
let
me now bring in my friend and colleague
Sean C professor of physics and
philosophy at John's Hopkins University
author of many books that I'm sure many
of you have read something deeply hidden
his book on quantum mechanics the big
picture his book on kind of
everything and then his book on the hour
of time and nature of time let me not
get the title wrong I'm doing this all
from memory but from eternity to
hear and I believe there's one other
that he will remind me of when he comes
in so please join me in welcoming Shan
Carol to the discussion hey how you
doing good Brian although after your
intro I'm worried I'm gonna get a lot of
questions about mirror symmetry that I'm
not gonna be able to uh help anybody
with hopefully you can chime in well
I'll jump in on those but um um did I
get all your books or did I leave no not
even close oh let me then help me out
here please got every title right that
you got got but I mean my most recent
book is called the biggest ideas in the
universe volume one
space time and motion so what I'm doing
in a three-part series of books is
explaining all the ideas of modern
physics with the equations to people who
don't know any equations so I teach you
calculus and in book one we go all the
way up to Einstein's equation and book
two is all of quantum mechanics and
Quantum field Theory effective field
Theory gauge Theory the higs mechanism
it's a lot of fun so let me ask you by
the end of book two can someone
calculate like a fan diagram or the uh
magnetic moment of uh the electron or
something like that they cannot but to
do that they should go to graduate
school but they will look at a findan
diagram and know what it means that's
the goal yeah yeah you know and I have
to ask you a question on on on books
it's an interesting thing because I
think you and I are both very similar we
take the language that we use very
seriously and we view the book itself as
more than just trying to convey
information it's meant to try to grab
you in a way that holds your attention
and Sparks your imagination but here's
the thing that that that's interesting
when you talk to people who've read your
books what fraction of them do you think
have really gotten what you were trying
to say and what fraction sort of come in
with a preconceived notion of how things
are and take away more or less what they
were looking for well I think it's a
great question but over the years uh you
know you and I have known each other for
long time so we've grown in wisdom since
we knew each other for the first time I
I perceive the purpose of a book or a
talk or a class or whatever as a little
bit different like I don't see people's
knowledge and opinions changing in
little spurts when you read a book when
you take a class I think that reading a
book might have a huge effect on someone
but they don't even know it because they
don't even recognize until five years
later you know or taking a class or
whatever so I I absolutely see people
read my books and then say things that
I'm like really you got that because I
didn't say that but I think that there's
a sort of larger vager yeah but
nevertheless overly o over mostly
positive impact that they had yeah no
hugely so and I think we view that you
know I mentioned you know these World
science postal events that we're doing
and we sort of see it obviously in the
same light namely you want to bring
people into these ideas and keep the
excitement going as at least to
counteract all the other nonsense that's
happening in the world and and if
someone takes away that level of
enthusiasm and excitement is actually
enough you know uh and if they take away
more you know it's really icing on the
cake there um and so so what's volume
three of this three volume set you
mentioned one and two volume three will
be complexity and emerg
so it's between you and me don't tell
anybody but everything that didn't fit
into volume one and volume two uh but
the theme will be you know more than two
particles colliding in a findan diagram
right it'll be many particles in the
collective behavior from cosmology to
thermodynamics up through complexity and
life so let why don't we jump off from
there you know with complexity and life
because that speaks to a question that
you and I have both spent some time
thinking about which is the arrow of
time you know this strange phenomenon
that the laws of physics which people
can now learn about at the level of
mathematical detail in the two books
that you've already mentioned those laws
of physics have this curious property
that seems counter to experience that
any process that happens in One
Direction with small caveats that we
don't need to get into right now the
reverse process can also happen and so
we have this beautiful symmetry in the
laws of physics between One Direction in
time and processes unfolding in the
reverse direction of time but yet in
everyday life it's anything but a
symmetry between between those things I
mean it's why we all laugh when people
run a reverse Run film of anything you
know people diving into a pool and
unding it's like it looks weird it's
funny cracking an egg unracking an egg
it looks odd so where do you think we
stand in trying to explain that tension
between experience
which doesn't show the Symmetry in the
way time unfolds but the laws of physics
that seem to have this built-in symmetry
well good I'm glad that we have these
eight hours to fill up so I can explain
this fully I mean it's a it's a rich
thing I'm teaching a whole first year
seminar course here at Johns Hopkins on
the AR philosophy uh this counts as a
Physics course um but I think maybe it's
also cross-listed in philosophy I'm not
sure but it's mostly physics we're doing
statistical mechanics Etc but we're also
watching some time travel movies just
because it's fun Y and I think that it's
a there's a lot for the perspective
historian of science to think about here
because the laws of physics being
symmetric with respect to time kind of
crept up on people right no one wanted
that no one ordered it no one even
remarked on it when it happened you know
once Newton had written down his
equations Newton was smart enough to say
like these work equally well forward or
backward but he didn't as far as I know
no uh it wasn't until LL over hundred
years later who first said you know if I
know exactly the state of the universe
at any one moment I know both the future
and the past perfectly well and there
was this gradual shift that wasn't
really completed until relativity came
on the scene According to which
physicists anyway started thinking of
all moments of time as real you know I
think that people who are have not been
poisoned by taking physics courses tend
to think of the world as the current
moment of time right that's reality and
then there will be a world doing
something different and I still feel
that way I still feel that way
intuitively of course you do right right
but suddenly the laws of physics are
implying a slightly separate story right
and so a new puzzle arose because of
this beautiful structure that we called
Newtonian mechanics and this this puzzle
has persisted with quantum mechanics and
relative and the whole bit why is the
past different from the future you know
the short answer to your question is I
think that we there's like one thing we
understand very very well and two things
we don't the thing we understand is
entropy is increasing entropy is a way
of measuring the disorderliness the
randomness the disorganization of
something yeah so we have a law the
second law of Thermodynamics that says
in a system left all to its own self if
you start it in a low entropy organized
State and it just wanders off it will
increase in entropy like you say you can
break the egg very easily Unbreaking the
egg doesn't happen very much and that's
simply that there are many ways to be
disordered compared to ordered so left
to its own devices it's going to find
one of the disordered States uh except
for the word simply yeah I agree with
everything you just said like this is
very contentious right you know people
really can find things to to worry
themselves but I think basically yes I
think that's basically it but then this
this leaves us two very very important
things still to be resolved by science
and philosophy for that matter one is
why was the entropy ever so low and the
the joke that I I'm sure my listeners
have these listeners have heard me say
before some a fraction of them the
reason why the entropy of the universe
was lower yesterday than it is today is
because it was even lower the day before
yesterday yeah and that's that is the
entire reason and then the reason why
that's true is because it was even lower
the day before that and you can play
this game for 14 billion years until you
hit the Big Bang so there's a puzzle for
cosmology that you and I have both
thought of very carefully which is why
was the conditions near the Big Bang so
low entropy and we I I would at least
say let's see what you say but we don't
know the answer to that uh that's that's
still on the table but then the other
thing looming in the background is I
would
claim that this fact that entropy is
increasing with time is the really the
only reason why the past is different
from the future fundamentally so we have
many manifestations of the arrow of time
the breaking of the egg but also our
memories only work in wonder I have
photographs on my phone of things in the
past I have no photographs of things in
the future causes precede effects we age
in the same d a million different ways
so we have to try to fill in that story
by explaining why all those phenomena
reduce to entropy increasing and that's
I'm very very interested in right now
yeah I mean the remarkable thing about
that too which I'm not sure everybody
appreciates but it obviously is implicit
in everything that you
said when we see some degree of order
today it actually is a remnant of the
extraordinary order that for whatever
reason was in place at the time of the
Big Bang so the very fact that you have
the egg that can then crack is because
we had that orderly State back then
because without that orderly State back
then there would be no order today and
therefore no opportunity for the entropy
to do what it ordinarily does yeah 100%
I mean the low entropy of the Big Bang
is the most valuable resource in the
universe and we're using it up we have a
long way to go there's not like an
entropy crisis like there is an energy
crisis but you're absolutely right the
way I put it is if you find a cracked
egg you think that there must have been
an uncracked egg sometime in the past
but the only only reason you have any
right to think that is because the early
Universe started with low entropy
whenever you're in the kitchen thinking
about how the mess occurred you're
implicitly relying on your knowledge of
what happened at the Big Bang now some
of the the audience no doubt because a
lot of the people listening here have
some familiarity or perhaps a deep
familiarity with cosmological Theory
such as inflationary cosmology which is
kind of the dominant Paradigm and no
doubt what may come to mind for those
listeners is well if the early Universe
underwent this rapid swelling that kind
of smoothed everything out and took you
know perhaps the curvature that had
might there flattened it all out and so
on is that a mechanism by which we can
assure ourselves of that low entropy and
of course I'm tossing you the softball
question because we know that doesn't
really work because I mean why don't you
take us through why that doesn't that
reason is natural but it doesn't really
work the reasoning is natural and it
might end up being a little part of the
solution as a whole but it's certainly
not itself the solution as a whole and I
think you and I can agree like that if
you pulled all physicists we might being
the minority there right I think a lot
of working cosmologists haven't really
coton on to this idea we have this idea
of the inflationary Universe which I
love I think it's great and Alan Guth
who helped invent the idea he and I and
Saki dulani are actually writing a paper
on the Arrow of time and its
relationship to inflation so hey wait a
second so you weren't you Allen's
student uh I was his postto postto okay
and sakshi was kind of my student so
this is incestuous little circle here
but yes keep going physics and
philosophy are both incestuous little
circle so I don't know if you know
sakshi is joining Johns Hopkins as a
post yes I did know that yeah you're
reminding me I'd forgotten but yes I do
remember now so she for those who don't
know out there she is a philosopher very
interested in physics and who knows a
lot about the arrow of time so we're
going to try to tackle some tricky
philosophical questions about infinity
and how to measure what is likely and
not and so forth but anyway that that's
that really is why it's such a tricky
question because there is a a way of
talking that is the following if you
have any little region of space that is
ready to inflate okay and by this we
mean a little region of space that has a
tremendously high density of energy in a
very specific form false vacuum energy
is what we call it but it's basically a
smooth patch of SpaceTime very very tiny
if it's in exactly the right conditions
it can literally grow and expand forever
right parts of it can grow and become
universes like ours other parts can keep
growing and become very different and
you make a whole Multiverse out of this
little tiny patch and that's one of the
Miracles of inflation and so there's one
point of view that says how hard can it
be to get one little patch of universe
ready to do that and there's very good
reasons to think it could be very very
hard and you have to work harder there
so I think that the question of why
inflation which is this little tiny
patch of space that expands to make a
big universe just like ours why it ever
would have started in the right way is
something that a lot of working
cosmologists will say oh come on you
know but I think it's crucially
important and just to say one more sort
of sociological thing when was in grad
school late 80s early 90s I was in an
astronomy department and there was a big
sociological divide at that time between
astronomers and physicists none of the
astronomers believed inflation this had
been proposed 10 years before right in
1980 but they said to themselves look
you've made one prediction namely the
universe is flat we've gone out and
measure the density of the universe it's
not enough to make the universe flat I'm
going to move on with my life but the
physicist love inflation because it was
kind of natural and elegant and whatever
and then 20 years pass and the tables
have completely turned the astronomers
love inflation because it makes extra
predictions about the density
perturbations in the early universe and
the microwave background it's highly
quantitative and you can match onto
things and so forth but many of the
physicists are saying to themselves well
are we sure that the story we told isn't
really cheating so that's what makes it
fun I think it's a great research area
right for two questions in in
one a quick one what fraction of the
physics Community do you think is really
convinced that inflation is the right
Paradigm for cosmology and what fraction
are willing to question that dominant
perspective right now well I think that
there's no close second competitor so to
me I would say that in my own personal
view I give inflation a 50% chance of
being right which is a giant percentage
chance for an incredibly speculative
theory of the very early universe but my
second best criteria my second best
Contender with like
48% is something we haven't thought of
yet right I don't have any good
Alternatives so inflation is good enough
and it has so weak competition I would
say right now that for most physicists
who care about these issues at all they
they tend to be pro- inflation uh you
say inflation yeah just to be clear
presumably you're talking about the
framework inflation that there was some
Source regardless of the details that
gave that energy density that gave rise
to this repulsive gravitational push
that led to all of the things that you
just described but you're not committed
to a particular incarnation of the
theory are you no not at all and in fact
this is one of the uh arrows in the
quiver of someone who would be
anti-inflation you know I I might have
given the impression saying that it
makes predictions and we're testing the
prediction
but really what I should say is it's
flexible enough to fit the data that we
have you know the data that we have is
from the observational point of view
highly precise and very very
quantitative but the input you need to
reproduce that data is actually just a
small number of parameters yeah uh it's
not like you're you're predicting a
hundred different numbers and then going
and measuring them all independently
you're predicting three numbers and then
you're measuring them and you can fit so
one of the things about is maybe it's
it's like you say a framework a family
of theories and it can fit the data but
it's not exactly as if maybe something
else couldn't either and what would it
take on the observational front for you
to come to the conclusion that inflation
is not the right
Theory well there
are okay let's let's back up uh in the
1990s before we discovered the dark
energy in the acceleration of the
universe that was a thing thing we did
in 1998 we found that
70% of the energy density of our
universe today is in this thing we call
dark energy and that that was a huge
Boon for inflation for various reasons
one of which is it filled in the missing
stuff that the astronomers 10 years
earlier were unable to identify it's
also a slow version of inflation you
know in terms of me that's the other
reason why it's so good the universe can
accelerate right which inflation needs
to have yeah so um be but before then
people were really worried about the
fact that the one prediction inflation
had made because we didn't have precise
measurements of the microwave background
or large scale structure either so the
one strong prediction of inflation was
the universe should be flat and it
didn't seem to be flat that is to say
the density of stuff in the universe
wasn't the amount predicted by inflation
because we didn't know about the dark
energy yet and so some very
with the theory and mess with it yeah so
that I can make it compatible with a
nonfat universe and there and I get why
they did that because they said I don't
have any second best theory if if my one
prediction comes wrong I'm gonna tweak
my theory to get that prediction right
I'm not going to give up on the theory
to me honestly that's still true you
know until we have a second best theory
it's hard for me to imagine one specific
observation that would make me say
inflation is wrong versus say
some weird version of inflation some
unexpected version is the right one so
it's super important for us as a field
to develop Alternatives yeah so what do
you think of and I I don't want to put
you on the spot at all but of course you
know you and I are both aware that Paul
steinhardt one of The Originators yeah
of the inflationary idea you mentioned
Alan Guth before there's Andre Lind
there's Paul steinhardt with Andreas
albrech usually described you know stra
bins also is put into the collection of
people who developed the key ideas in
recent years Paul rather vocally and
energetically has said he no longer
believes in inflation even though he was
one of the people who thought of it and
has put forward this other approach
indeed we're going to have a little
session at our events in September where
he's going to describe cyclical ideas to
cosmology where do you come down on on
the position that Paul has now staked
out I think there's two aspects of his
position well let's let's just back up
Paul is great he's super duper smart I'm
going to listen to anything he says
whether or not I believe him he's worth
paying attention to um this position
that you just outlined I I would
separate into two separate positions one
is he thinks he has alternatives to
inflation and the other is whether or
not he has Alternatives he thinks that
inflation is uh untenable just as a
theory all by itself so on the
Alternatives I am very happy that he's
developing them I am completely
unimpressed with the ability of the
alternatives to actually do their jobs
largely for reasons related to The Arrow
of time actually I think that unlike
inflation which does not solve the arrow
of Time problem but might play a role in
an ultimate solution I think the cyclic
and bouncing cosmologies are are pretty
hopeless when it comes to the arrow of
time I might be wrong about that this is
my personal point of view but that's why
I'm not personally dropping things and
and spending time on on studying that
the other argument I think is very
interesting and it's a it's a legitimate
challenge Paul says the following you
know as I just mentioned once inflation
starts it's not hard and maybe it's even
more likely than not that it keeps going
forever what we call Eternal inflation
and then again we don't know but more
likely than not you can get regions of
the universe with all sorts of wild
different conditions right that's what
gives rise to the cosmological
Multiverse so Paul's point is pretty
simple the whole idea of inflation was
to say no matter where you started you
ended up in a universe that looks like
ours and now it says if you start in
this specific place you end up in all
possible universes so predicts nothing
it can get a region the universe where
it looks like anything then what are you
predicting and I I absolutely abely feel
the force of that worry but to me it's
not a showstopper it's a challenge we
need to better understand how to make
probabilistic predictions in this kind
of scenario and and guess what we need
philosophy as well as physics to help us
with that yeah know it's interesting so
a couple years ago Paul and I had a
energetic Email exchange H about these
issues um a friendly Email exchange I
mean like you I have the same opinion
that Paul's one of the great physicist
of our age and uh it's always a joy to
argue with him because it always is
enlightening even if you don't fully
agree with the position but yes I would
say that a big part of the issue is
indeed as you just mentioned if a theory
can give rise to many different
universes or subuniverses within a large
universe or universes within a
Multiverse whatever language you like to
use then what kind of predictions does
it make and of course the natural answer
that many in the inflationary cosmology
Community will offer is well we just
need to work out a so-called measure on
the space of universe as much as you're
noting something that gives us a measure
of the probability the likelihood of
this universe versus that universe and
hopefully our universe would be
relatively High measure a likely outcome
of this process and that perhaps would
give us some confidence that these ideas
are right but Paul's response to that is
hey Brian and rest of you inflationary
cosmology proponents this measure that
you talk about that's doing all the work
of your theory and so to just think of
it as well we just need this extra
little piece is perhaps a little bit
disingenuous and and and that may be the
Crux of where he's coming from yeah and
I think that's fair of course since the
the other thing that I would say on his
side is we don't have the measure so uh
to say that it's yeah doing all the work
I don't know whether it's doing all the
work because we don't have it yet but
let me uh raise another thing I'm sure
the listeners will enjoy which is the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics which I'm a fan of in many
worlds when I do a measurement of a
Quantum system right here in the office
right I don't need to look at the
cosmology or anything like that I
measure a spin in a undergraduate
laboratory and the rules of quantum
mechanics as far as observers notice is
that there's a probability
that you get spin up or spin down and
many world says there's a world where
you get spin up with 100% probability in
some world and there's going to be some
world with 100% probability where you
got spined down so there's a huge
challenge as you know hanging out at
Columbia with David Albert and other
people there's a huge challenge to many
world's Advocates how do you recover
this measure this probability and I
think you can do it in that case I think
the data have guided us uh because we do
quantum mechanics experiments we know in
the case of many worlds precisely what
measure we need to get and we get it you
know it's it's the one that is sort of
most natural but that again this is very
fertile ground for a collaboration
between physics and philosophy because I
think that careful thinking about what
it means to be a probability what it
means to be Infinity how you deal with
these uh tricky problems has a very good
chance of answer answering these
questions in the inflationary context
just like it does in the many worlds
context so in fact there are some who
have made an argument that the many
worlds of many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics and the many
universes of internal inflation May in
fact be one and the same thing so
answering one through some complex chain
of translations may take you from one
articulation of the answer to one
problem to an articulation of the answer
to the other now I am tempted to go down
this rout of quantum mechanics that you
have opened up here however I am
reluctant to do so because as I
mentioned at the outset you and I are
going to do a live conversation we got
time for that in in New York in in
September 23rd Saturday again anyone
who's around September 23rd I should say
this is 2023 in case you're watching
this in the years's
2037 and you're going to clear your
calendar for September 23rd so for all
those who are not fans of closed Tim
like curves just ignore what I just said
and we'll just carry on with other
things that we can talk about but I want
to go back to this issue of how perhaps
inflationary expansion might have gotten
started because one other answer that
has historical antecedence really comes
from boltzman who was thinking about
these ideas of entropy as disorder and
how sure the second law of
Thermodynamics says that entropy
increases but it's not a law in the
traditional sense of a law something
that can't be violated rather it's an
overwhelming tendency that entropy will
increase but as we all know there can be
unusual
fluctuations in which there is order
produced as opposed to disorder and
boltzman himself imagined that perhaps
the order that we see right now now
could have been preceded by a whole long
history of disorder and who cares how
long that era of disorder lasted so long
if sooner or later the rarest
fluctuation well not the rarest but a
really rare fluctuation happened
dropping us down to the low entropy
configuration from which the world as we
know it could then slowly emerge as the
world went back up the entropy Hill of
course you can imagine a similar kind of
set of words for inflation
cosmology early Universe I don't even
know what I mean by that but way back
when there's this wild undulation of
everything every field curvature and so
forth and this energy field we usually
call the inflaton field but it's that
energy that little packet of energy that
we needed to start inflation that you
made reference to it may have just threw
sheer chance after eons and eons even
though that word isn't even Define back
then somehow it coalesces into this nice
smooth patch of energy and then
everything goes forward from there is
that a convincing scenario in your mind
or is that somehow
cheating convincing would be a slight
exaggeration I think uh you know I I do
think that something like that is very
plausibly on the right track I mean as
you know I wrote a paper with Jennifer
Chen years ago where we suggested that
the way to ask this question rather than
to say here is the most natural initial
condition to start with because it's
pretty and simple and so forth we can
ask ourselves the question what does the
highest entropy state of the universe
look like and actually years later I
wrote another paper with another student
Aiden Chatwin Davis where we where we
finally to my satisfaction showed that
in a universe like ours the highest
entropy state is empty space we're
moving toward that in our universe now
right our universe is not only expanding
but acceler ating we think that we have
some vacuum energy that is pushing us
apart it's never going to go away so if
we wait long enough 10 to the 100 years
from now will be empty space with no
stars no planets no galaxies no black
holes anything like that that is the
highest entropy State the universe could
be in so the real question for cosmology
in my mind is why don't we live in the
highest entropy immediately from the
GetGo yeah why don't we always live
there yeah answer is anthropic and this
isort the modern version of boltzman's
thing because he boltzman didn't know
about general relativity or the cosmical
constant so he would have said if we
think of the universe like a box of gas
that gas should be in equilibrium right
it should be the same temperature
everywhere the same density everywhere
that would be the highest entropy State
why don't we live there now that's not
that's not exactly correct because
there's something called gravity but
that's okay it's it's a whole story but
boltzman's answer was if you wait long
enough you will fluctuate downward in
entropy just like you said it was one of
Bol B's answers I I very much encourage
people to directly go back and read
boltzman's papers from the 1890s they're
readable and they're kind of funny and
he's wildly inconsistent he says well
clearly the answer to this problem is
very simple it could be this or it could
be this or it could be this and he gives
completely incompatible stories so maybe
it's not so simple but anyway the modern
version would be can you start in that
high y empty space yeah and somehow
fluctuate upward in entropy to something
that would look like inflation from
which you would then settle back down to
a universe like ours and this is It's
wildly hubristic even to talk about this
kind of thing that's why they pay us the
big bucks to talk about it because we
don't know what we're doing we don't
know whether the system is infinite or
finite we don't know how quantum gravity
works we don't know a million things so
I would like something like that to be
true I can't promise you that anything
like that has been completely sold out
right now one one one aspect of it that
I think does fall out quite naturally is
that time doesn't have a single Arrow
but two different arrows it has one
arrow in our universe and in the whole
Multiverse around us but if we go to the
far far far far far past the arrow of
time points in the Direction and there's
toward the super far past and the super
far future entropy is increasing both
directions and I think you recover the
Symmetry that we started with yeah
exactly exactly and that and I to me
that's much more satisfying and it fits
together more so than the cyclic
Universe for example or just starting
the universe in some weird boundary
condition so you know if if one thinks
about high entropy in the early Universe
versus the low entropy be condition that
we know had to Prevail in order to be
compatible with our own
observations usually we imagine that
high enty configuration differing from
what we put into our equations when we
want that low entry starting point by
virtue of the gravitational degrees of
freedom being highly excited in the
early stages versus them not being
highly excited right lots of black holes
filling space you know things things of
that sort and you know a paper that I
wrote a while ago that you were not a
great fan of which is which is fine but
the basic
idea I'm a fan of anyone writing papers
about the early Universe in the arrow of
time you know the idea that that
occurred to me uh and a couple of other
folks at Columbia at the time was look
if by some means the gravitational
strength was extraordinarily lower maybe
turned off in the early universe and
that could explain why the gravitational
degrees in Freedom were not excited now
of course the mechanism of turning off
the gravitational degrees of freedom
that becomes the devil in the details
because you don't want to turn it off in
a way that somehow is slipping low
entropy in the back door now I don't
know enough about it but I probably
should but I've read that the loop
quantum gravity people believe there's a
natural means by which the gravitational
strength would indeed be turned off
analogous to what we were writing about
in that paper are you familiar with what
those guys are saying and and and uh
whether or not that's a viable means of
not exciting the gravitational degrees
of freedom in the early Universe I have
not heard of that no I haven't um I
would say you know just one for me
guiding principle which was emphasized
by Hugh price who is another philosopher
of physics is that if you want to
explain the asymmetry of time in our
universe by appealing to fundamentally
time time symmetric dynamical laws like
we think we have you'd better have the
far future and the far past look the
same and I'm not sure that that kind of
model does that right right yeah it's a
good it's a good point I don't know the
answer either in that
particular again I think that not nearly
enough people are thinking about this
even if Brian's model or my model are
not the right ones maybe some young
person listening to this will go figure
out the right one and mention us in
their Nobel Prize Acceptance Speech but
it is a very interesting
sociological question you know when I
think of the great physicists of you
know the the early 1900s mid
1900s I do think of them and maybe it's
just a romantic notion as both
physicists and philosophers people
really bound up with with the big ideas
and yet it seems like in a number of
Arenas quantum mechanics being one of
them and again I'm reluctant to go too
far into the details but we can talk at
a more General
level why weren't they more worried
about some of the philosophical issues
of quantum mechanics which can actually
even be thought of as physics issues
really but there seemed to be a
significant focus on on you know getting
the calculations matching them to
experiment but then not pushing that one
step further to really say okay what the
heck does this mean for reality
and is this giving us a sensible picture
of the world I mean Einstein did a
little bit but you know even in eppr it
was P&R that wrote the epr paper and Ein
gonna get stuck on it but any was
concerned with the issues so and there
was certainly an era I mean I'm a little
bit older than you but not hugely so you
know I was doing my post-doctoral work
in the in the 80s and there was
definitely a sense of stay away from the
philosophers we just put them to the
side so so where did this kind of
cyclical behavior in terms of our
respect for philosophy come from and
where do you think we are now in that
cycle yeah and and just to be super
clear it's not even a question of
respect philosophy but a a question of
the respect for these kinds of
foundational questions yeah yeah to you
and I it's natural to associate that
with philosophy because the philosophers
get it they're very much interested in
these foundational questions right uh
whereas physicists exactly like you said
I mean historically during our lifetimes
uh have not wanted to do that and I
think it I don't I I try to be super
fair right like it's easy to paint the
people you disagree with as kind of
Dopey um if if I try to give the
strongest possible argument for the
strategy that was taken over the last 50
years of ignoring the foundations of
quantum mechanics I would say it was
hard to know how to make progress yeah
even if you thought the question was
important when you when you as you know
you had grad students you like train
them not only solve the equations but
also pick the right problems to work on
and I think that uh for a long time you
know we didn't know about decoherence
entanglement like most people who even
today take an undergraduate quantum
mechanics course don't learn about
entanglement I certainly didn't yeah
exactly so I think that a lot of people
there was such a richness of really good
questions to be addressed in Quantum
field Theory and in condensed matter
physics and in astrophysics and in
general relativity why would you spend
your time banging your head against the
quantum measurement problem I think
that's that would be the attitude I
don't agree with it yeah yeah I think
that there's productive um progress to
be made bangging your head against that
problem but I'm guessing that was the
reason they just didn't see how to make
that progress yeah and again they could
do just for those of the again I'm sure
everybody knows the language but just to
fill in you know Quantum measurement
problems the idea is how do you go from
the fuzzy Haze of possibilities Allowed
by the quantum probabilities to the
single definite reality of experience
upon measurement or observation or some
kind of interaction how does that
actually happen and you mentioned David
Albert before you know he's a
philosopher here at Colombia you know
when I first came to Colombia as a young
man back in whatever that was
1995 or six or something like that this
philosopher David Albert gets in touch
with me and he says I want to have lunch
with you I didn't know who he was at the
time but I was game to meet new people
at Colombia and we had an an incredibly
enlightening lunch for me because my
attitude toward quantum mechanics at
that point was quantum mechanic done
deal that's what I've been taught
graduate school I'd used it nobody had
Ever Raised any issues about it at all
sure i' heard the measurement issue a
little bit but my attitude was if you're
pushed to the wall it's the many worlds
interpretation then you just gota you
just gotta kind of make it work and and
so obviously you know David as well as I
do he wasn't having any of that
nonsense no and you know so we sat there
for hours and I had walked into that as
you know Mr physicist and I kind of
walked out a little bit with my tail
between my legs because he had raised
issues that I couldn't fully address and
I was surprised that I couldn't address
some foundational issues in quantum
mechanics it was something that I wasn't
I wasn't fully aware of them so I know
there are some in our community who
still are very much you know put the
philosophers to the side they've never
done anything for physics I've certainly
heard some of our colleagues say things
like that I can say firsthand they've
certainly done stuff for me and and I
think they've definitely done important
work for the field as a whole because um
while you and I may be in the minority
I'm pretty convinced that they
foundational open issues and quantum
mechanics that still need attention
before we can really say that this is a
done deal and we fully understand it
well enough to say that uh uh reality
according to Quantum Mechanics is
something that we understand I mean I
assume you're in a similar frame of mind
oh 100% you feel that you've solved it
by now which could be a you know I wrote
an article when something deeply hidden
came out I I put an OP ad in the New
York Times complaining about the fact
that physicists don't understand quantum
mechanics and I was sure I was going to
get deluged with uh emails from
physicist saying well I understand
quantum mechanics I only got one I will
not reveal who it was from but you know
most of the physicists are were like
yeah actually I'm glad you're pointing
this out so I do think that maybe people
are softening up a little bit I I think
that if anything it's not you know I
would like to think that it's because of
philosophers and people like me who are
philosophy the adjacent you know telling
them they should I think it's technology
that changes how people view these
things we're building quantum computers
now we're doing we're using the
resources of quantum mechanics in a way
that are much less is much less
simple-minded than we had to use it like
people can talk about the the absolute
genius contributions of fan and Weinberg
and and Salam Etc gmon but and it was
all based in quantum mechanics and
Quantum field Theory but to a really
large ENT it was a very simple
application of quantum mechanics right
like the field Theory and the
calculation is very very subtle and
complicated but all they were doing was
calculating a wave function and squaring
it to get a probability at the end of
the day and so the the facts about
measurement and entanglement and what it
all means and like they didn't need to
worry about those things but when you're
building a quantum
computer suddenly there's this thing
called decoherence you know interacting
with the environment and sharing
entanglement around suddenly entangle
lement is a resource suddenly you have
to understand this stuff and you know
whether you've ever listened to a
philosopher in your life or not suddenly
the foundations of quantum mechanics
seems like a little bit more respectable
to you yeah yeah and again um just to go
there a little bit so again for those in
the audience entanglement no doubt
you've heard is this idea that you can
have two particles in quantum mechanics
that can be far apart from one another
but in a mathematically precise way act
as though they
one or right next to each other you
measure one of these particles and it
seems to have an instantaneous influence
on the other this of course is what
Einstein called spooky action at a
distance he said that as a pejorative
not a wow reaction at a distance it was
not like wow cool how can you Quantum
mechanicians or quantum mechanics people
believe in a theory that has that sort
of quality which leads to a rich and
wonderful history of ideas that no doubt
you and I will have some time to talk
about next Saturday at our live event in
New York City if if Carlo and at least
let us have a word in edgewise I mean
people have a lot to say so yeah no that
that's that that will be arranged so I
think I think we'll be all all good on
that front but it's interesting you
mentioned the New York Times and the OPB
that you wrote and the only you know one
response that was of the sort that you
were concerned about I wrote an
oped back in
2005 which was on you know the
anniversary of special relativity and
sort of explaining some of the ideas and
equals mc squared was one of those
things and in that article I tried to
undo a
misunderstanding that E equals MC s is
only relevant for nuclear processes I
think there's
a yeah and so I got all these angry
responses mostly from chemists and I'm
not trying to diss any chemists perhaps
who are listening to us who said how
could you have gotten that wrong how
could you possibly mislead the public
equals MC squ is only relative to
nuclear only relevant to nuclear
processes and it was so interesting to
me how a whole community of scientists
had somehow missed the boat I mean
obviously many chemists do know
correctly but but
you don't need to know it yeah yeah
that's right you don't need to know it
and and there's the there's this kind of
lore that can settle in and and infect a
whole generation of thinkers if they
don't encounter it in some way that
makes them grapple with it more fully
you know and I think the same same thing
with quantum mechanics and entanglement
the way that I say it is that physicists
uh to their credit they care a lot about
getting the right answer they don't care
about getting the right answer for the
right reason they're very happy to give
false understandings of why they got the
right answer whether it's Quantum field
Theory or the measurement problem also
special relativity but but uh the arrow
of time is a huge example of this I I
taught a course last year at Johns
Hopkins on the philosophy you know
topics in the philosophy of physics and
I had a couple of physicists take the
class and I had one woman who was a
student who you know when we were
talking about the arrow of time and I
said look unless you make some time
asymmetric assumption somewhere you're
not going to derive that the past is
different from the future and she said
oh no I just had my stat Mech course and
you know my professor told us how to do
it I said and I said no no they did
not discussion about it as usual you
could find exactly the place where they
smuggled in right in assumption but it's
all over the place which is which is why
you know the the foundations maybe the
there's still it's it's not just that
it's important to get things right and
tidy things up I think that we're in a
we're in a moment of time in the history
of fundamental physics where there's
some looming questions we don't know
precisely how to make progress on them
whether it's particle physics or
cosmology or gravity or whatever it's
kind of a natural thing to step back and
say okay without strict experimental
guidance let's reexamine all the details
about how we got here and ask how we
might do something different yeah in
terms of experimental guidance you know
there's some wonderful astronomical
things that are happening right you got
the Simon Observatory you got uid you
got the Nancy G Roman's telescope I mean
there's all sorts of wonderful data what
do you think on the particle physics
front so you know Large Hadron Collider
was developed to find the higs particle
July 4th 2012
fantastic you know that was there and
that oh you were at CERN oh that's
beautiful you know it must have been
quite emotional I would imagine you know
for that to happen I mean just for
people to know this is an idea that
began as a mathematical idea in the
1960s Peter higs and glair others as
well who didn't share in the prize but a
number of individuals gave a mechanism
by which the ordinary particles that
inhabit the world around us could have
acquired the masses that they have but
it was a completely theoretical idea and
I'm I'm slightly embarrassed to say but
I will say it anyway because I've said
it before when I was a graduate student
and we learned about the higs mechanism
by which particles would acquire their
Mass I did not realize that this was a
hypothetical idea it was taught with
such certainty I'm sure the the
professor yeah so I for a long time I
was like of course it's the higs idea I
didn't know that it was still a waiting
confirmation but you know I was
disabused of that notion you know in the
ensuing years and then so this
mathematical idea goes from equations in
the 60s to experiments searching for the
predictions of those equations to
confirmation in 2012 that's the journey
that's the journey that is like the
Prototype of of of excitement and it's
spectacular that it happened but the
machine was also built for another
reason you know obviously one reason is
find something unexpected of course
that's most ex of all but there's this
thing called super symmetry that you
know the super and super symmetry is the
same super as and super String Theory an
idea that's certainly close to to my
heart and things that I've spent time on
we had hoped that a whole class of
particles the super symmetric partners
of The Gnome particles will be found and
they've not been found as yet at the
large hron collider so where do you
think that leaves particle physics and
and where do you see things going
honestly I think you're underselling the
weirdness of it because it's absolutely
true that we were hoping to see super
symmetry but even if you are a partisan
of some alternative to Super symmetry
there were tremendously good reasons to
think we would find something at the
large adron collider not only be for for
two reasons which I think are worth
laying out one is there's dark matter in
the universe and a popular model for
dark matter is weekly interacting
massive particles maybe from Super
symmetry maybe from something else but
the word weak there means the weak
interactions of particle physics and
this energy scale that the large hydron
collider looks at for the first time in
human history is around the weak energy
scale so just the fact that there's Dark
Matter fits very naturally with the idea
that there's more particles to be found
at that scale and then there's what we
call the hierarchy problem uh the H
mechanism for understanding symmetry
breaking in and particle masses works
very well but if you just naively write
down the equations and make a
theoretical guess as to the energy scale
of that uh which gives the energy and
mass to all these other particles it
should be much higher than it actually
is so there's a big hierarchy between
the higs mass or equivalently the weak
scale the high energy scales of particle
physics Grand unification plank scale
what have you and again super Symmetry
and other models that purported to be
solutions to the hierarchy problem
predicted a bunch of new particles at
the LHC
so I was very surprised I was not
surprised to see the higs uh I was not a
super partis in for super symmetry in
particular like I I tend to be you know
uh pretty ecumenical in my models so I
don't know what it was going to be but I
really would have bet a lot of money at
even money that we would find something
yeah Archy problem so I have made
lemonade out of out of these lemons um
my current sort of hopeful guess is that
the reason why we haven't seen anything
at the Large Hadron cider and the reason
why we nevertheless have a hierarchy
problem is because of a deep issue with
Quantum field Theory and quantum gravity
that we don't understand and and again
I'm going to keep saying it but ripe for
philosophy physics um uh collaborations
here
because the large hadon we spent n
billion dollars building the Large
Hadron Collider and in some very real
sense the motivation was naturalness
right the naturalness of the value of
the higs go on yeah that's a problematic
term to spend a lot of money chasing
down when you haven't completely defined
it or you know Etc so uh you know I'm
kind of hopeful I I both want to have a
better understanding of what we mean
mean by naturalness which also feeds
right back into the measure problem and
internal inflation and things like that
and it also and also I I think that
we're sort of being cheap and easy about
extending our ideas of quantum field
Theory up to high energy scales that
lead us to the hierarchy problem Etc
because we know there is quantum gravity
in the universe we know there is
something you know we can go into it at
Great length things like the holography
uh principle the black hole information
puzzle I think that it's perfectly clear
that Quantum field theory is not the
final answer to what the universe is
it's some relative and it certainly like
Quantum field Theory at low energies but
I would love for the absence of
particles at the Large Hadron CER to be
the first good clue that we really have
to make a bold leap Beyond Quantum field
Theory yeah I mean it's a very uh
optimistic interpretation which is which
is a good one and I can't help but also
emphasizing
you made a mention of dark matter and
the natural way that super symmetric
particles could have could have been the
dark matter just to underscore that when
you consider a potential Dark Matter
candidate what we as physicists as you
know need to do is you need to follow
the number of those dark matter
particles that would persist until today
based upon how many would have been the
natural number in the Eur Universe based
on thermodynamic equilibrium and so on
and the
remarkable
unbelievable fact that without
fine-tuning any
parameters super symmetric particles the
most basic ones would persist in just
the right abundance to be the dark
matter how could it have not been the
case that super symmetric particles are
the dark matter it was such a convincing
argument and yet so far it's seems that
it's it's not the case so we can really
be misled by these ideas of of
naturalness these ideas of fine-tuning
you know you really do need to take
these ideas and shake them really hard
because you can absorb them as yes of
course it has to be that but then the
universe sometimes will Accord that kind
of reason but sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it doesn't I will never forget
um there's another famous coincidence
that is very similar to this the M
coincidence yeah uh if you look at a
Galaxy you look at lots of different
galaxies they all need Dark Matter to
explain their rotation and their
structure Etc but uh morai mgrm noticed
this absolutely fascinating and
potentially important fact inside a
certain radius in each Galaxy you don't
need Dark Matter the visible matter is
perfectly good to explain the Dynamics
is always a radius that is sort of the
crossover point from where inside you
don't need it outside you do and he said
I bet I could just change the theory of
gravity or inertia is what he actually
did and the very remarkable thing is
that this crossover radius it's
different for different galaxies but the
what it numerically works out to be is
the radius when the acceleration due to
gravity is a certain number and that
number is the speed of light times the
Hubble constant today and the Hubble
constant is not a constant right it
changes as the universe expands and it
should have nothing to do with each
other those two numbers this radius at
which you need dark matter and the
expansion rate of the universe they
should be unrelated yeah and I remember
vividly sitting at a cosmology
conference in Princeton and Milgram gave
his talk and he explains this and I was
sitting next to Juan Mala who we know is
you know a friend and one of the great
string theorists and and thinkers of the
world and he leans over to me and says
is that true that there's this
coincidence and I said yeah and he goes
it must be right then he was ready to
give up on dark matter and replace it
with modified gravity and I said well
yes but sometimes there are just
coincidences and I think that's right
you know gravity could be modified but
dark matter I think is real so nature is
not being quite kind to us yet yeah
although even that's a little bit still
up in the air what exactly the
resolution's going to be I mean there's
a lot of circumstantial evidence for
dark matter but the failure to find it
where does that does it not shake you up
at all or you just say hey look there's
so many possible candidates for what it
might be and there's so many parts of
parameter space that we've not yet
explored so yeah we haven't found it yet
we will so I I I am not shook not shook
yet about Dark Matter uh to me for two
two reasons number one if you go back
and look
at especially the cosmic microwave
background radiation which is by far our
best evidence for dark matter but also
things like the bullet cluster and other
other things I to me and I'm kind of an
extremist on this not everyone agrees
but they should I think we know that
dark matter exists we might also modify
gravity that I'm a big fan of I've
written papers I love modifying gravity
but I think that we've crossed a
threshold where we have enough evidence
empirically to say that dark matter of
some sort has to exist and the other
thing is you know the like you say
there's lots of candidates for what the
dark matter is I I I gave just a few
years ago a talk where I was asked to
you know in our old uh phase now we're
asked to give talks like what is the
state of the field you know so uh I but
I knew that a lot of the audience
members were super symmetry fans and you
know weekly interacting massive particle
fans so I did something almost no one
ever does which is you always see these
plots for dark matter experiments of
here's the theoretical you know differ
models that could predict different
cross-sections here are the limits and
here our limits yeah and then as we get
new limits we erase all the predictions
that are incompatible with the limits
right so I actually went back and found
a plot from before we had done any of
the LHC or any of the weekly interacting
massive particle detectors and I I
looked at their predicted range of
parameters and this was a couple years
ago but roughly speaking we had ruled
out about 50% of the ameter space as
we'd understood it Circ the year 2000 so
I can't be that surprised by that
failure but also something called the ax
on and there's other Dark Matter
candidates so we're not basis point yet
the fact that we haven't found the dark
matter so I said we take questions I do
see one question from our audience which
uh a basic one but an important one
which is a questioner notes that they
always mix up dark matter and dark
energy and can we just give a little
explanation so feel free to jump in on
that one if you would show that that's
pretty easy I mean honestly I wish they
had been named something a little bit
more dramatically different from each
other you know we we have these three
components that that at least are
important to the universe ordinary
matter the kinds of matter that we find
here on Earth in in the lab about 5% of
the matter of the total energy budget of
the universe dark matter is matter it's
kind of like it's a particle probably
maybe tiny black holes but it's
something like that comes in discreet
chunks and can evolve like we know a lot
about dark matter we know how much of it
there is we know where it is we know
kind of how it evolves and it's 25% of
the mass of the universe probably it's
some particle we haven't detected yet
and then the dark energy we don't even
need that name in in in my view because
the dark energy is some kind of energy
that is smoothly spread throughout space
and doesn't
dilute away as the universe expands so
the the first guess is that it is
perfectly smooth and perfectly constant
and that is exactly what Albert Einstein
gave us in 1917 what he called the
cosmological constant what modern
physicists call the vacuum energy and
it's a perfectly good fit as far as I
have have seen the plots to all of the
data we have about Dark Energy but you
know we fooled ourselves before we
discovered the Dark Energy like you
would have won money off of me if you
had said in 1995 70% of the energy of
the universe is the cosmological
constant I would have said no that's
unnatural etc etc and we were wrong so
once we did discover the acceleration of
the universe we say okay let's let's be
more cautious now sure there's a very
natural candidate that was given to us
by Einstein and it fits all the data but
it might not be right so we allow for
the possibility that the dark matter is
something Dark Energy rather is
something dynamical it's not just a
fixed constant it changes slightly not
yet observably and we go look for it and
that's a very worthwhile thing to do we
build telescopes we do the observations
if we find that the dark energy is not
quite constant then that would be hugely
hugely important and again my interest
is that we do that I've written papers
on exactly that possibility I would love
it if that were true there's different
ways to do it but my bet at even money
once again is that Einstein was you know
got right yet again and it's just a
vacuum energy but it's interesting the
Einstein right Einstein wrong in that
because one of the famous quotes it was
a secondary quote I think Gau was the
one who said that Einstein claimed that
the cosmological constant was his
biggest blunder as the saying goes when
it was realized that the universe is
expanding because Einstein introduced it
to try to make the universe static but
the fact of the matter is there is a
verifiable quote of Einstein's where he
says that it would be future
observations that would determine
whether the cosmological member the
cosmological constant is actually part
of reality so he recognized actually
that it was an interesting possibility
it naturally fit into the equations and
that we didn't have the data back in his
era to really determine whether or not
it was part of reality and so I don't
think he would even be that surprised
necessarily I mean it's usually framed
as Einstein threw it away when the
universe of and smacked himself in the
head and now even Einstein's wrong ideas
are right which would make you think
that he would be oh my God this is
insane that bad idea that I threw away
is actually true but I think he'd be
like yeah I suspected that observations
in the future would determine whether it
was right or wrong let me ask one final
question because I know that you need to
go make dinner and uh I don't want do it
yeah I don't I don't want to exhaust
everything that uh we can talk about uh
we should do this again sometime and as
well as we'll do it live in in New York
on the 23rd but I've read some papers I
consider them a little bit on the um
fringy side but wonder if you've
encountered these that if you look at
certain data that makes us potentially
question homogenate and isotropy which
of course is underlying all the
mathematical analysis by which we come
to the conclusion that we need to have
dark energy there are some models which
suggest suggest that you don't need Dark
Energy if you if you give things up in
the in the right way and that there may
be some evidence for
that have you looked at any of those and
what do you think I am uh yeah highly
non-conveniens that it's just like some
person in their basement with a theory
like you and I get those in the email
all the time this is not that these are
cons cosmologists um I don't think it
works for two three reasons I have some
reasons but you know if it was one good
reason that's all I would need right um
one is I think the right way to think
about this is using what is known as
effective field Theory um there's this
set of techniques that that we use in
theoretical physics to sort of bundle up
uh things that we don't completely
understand right in particle physics you
can say I can totally well predict the
probability of to electron scattering
without knowing whether super string
theory is right you know there are ways
that I can make low energy predictions
without knowing everything about what
happens at arbitrarily High energies and
I think that if you use that technique
in cosmology which has become uh
increasingly popular in recent years you
can include a term which is essentially
the nominal Dark Energy contribution
from large scale structure and it's very
very negligibly small and the the the
other reason I would give the other
respectable reason is um intuitively it
makes no sense at all so what people are
saying is you know we we model the
universe by having matter and energy be
completely homogeneous we solve our
equations and and for certain purposes
that's supposed to be okay but the real
world is is clumpy right there's
galaxies and so forth so let's add in a
correction from including the clumpiness
right and there's a way to do that
formally
which much like Quantum field Theory
gives you an answer that is
infinity and then and you say well it's
Infinity in this calculation clearly the
calculation is wrong but because it's
Infinity maybe it's big maybe it's
noticeable and I don't I don't think
that's the right logic to use there
because intuitively what you're saying
is we know the effect of stars and
galaxies and dark matter and it's to
decelerate the universe we're asking
what is the effect of the gravitational
field of the stars and galaxies on the
expansion of the universe but everything
we know about general relativity is that
that's a small effect squared right I
mean that's a small effect times a small
effect so your intuition is this should
not matter and I think it doesn't matter
I think that the the third reason is
there are people who have spent much
more time than me looking at it who said
no it doesn't work yeah right which is a
a pretty good indication as well but yes
all three well look it's it's been a a
great pleasure spending this time with
you Sean I'm looking forward again if
you're watching this in the year 2037
ignore what I'm about to say but uh 2023
September 23rd of 2023 Sean and I
together with Carlo relli and leis Crow
are gonna talk about quantum mechanics
in New York City live and iners 4 pm so
if you're interested in around New York
City at that time please join us so
looking forward to seeing you then in
person Sean it's been a while I'm
looking forward to convincing Carlo and
Elise that many worlds is right this is
my chance there we go so we can duke it
out on stage so thanks a lot for joining
us and we will see you then all right
everybody else let me just uh say a
couple words before wrapping it up
there's one point that Sean made that
someone else asked about in the question
so I might just quickly address it which
is can we make a prediction for the
amount of dark energy that we believe to
be suffusing space responsible for the
accelerated expansion that was observed
in 1998 and here's the crazy thing and
this is really kind of nuts right we can
measure the amount of dark energy
necessary to explain our observations as
Sean mentioned is about 70% of the
entire mass energy budget of the
universe when we try to actually do the
calculation though we get a number that
is huge compared to that if you look at
the quantum fluctuations in the vacuum
every single mode every single
wavelength contributes the amount of
Zero Point Energy or dark energy that
would be out there and when you add up
over an infinite number of modes
unsurprisingly you get the infinite
answer that we heard reference to and so
this is perhaps the greatest mismatch in
the history of physics between something
that's been observed and measured the
amount of dark energy and our attempts
to calculate that number they differ
even if you put in natural cut offs
Beyond which we can't really trust our
theoretical calculation still the answer
that you get is about 10 to the 120
times
larger than the amount that we observe
right a mismatch of a factor of 10 to
the 120 and so this is a beautiful
example of some indication of deep lack
of complete understanding and and I say
that not with my head held low in shame
but rather with my head held high in the
excitement of all it is that we still
need to learn all that we still need to
figure out so that's really the state of
our understanding there are some deep
problems that we have solved there's
some deep problems yet to be resolved
and I hope that some of you in the
audience will be inspired to think about
these questions get an undergraduate
degree in physics a graduate degree and
really join in the ranks in the in the
Relentless March of humanity and trying
to understand the universe at its
deepest level again if you're in New
York September 21 to 24 of the Year 2023
we're going to do our first Live Events
World Science Festival events something
called science in September six
interesting conversations artificial
intelligence cosmology quantum mechanics
with Sean Carlo relli Elise croll and
others we got a handful of Nobel
laurates we've got breakthrough Prize
winners touring Prize winners so it's
going to be an exciting handful of days
and so please join us if you are in New
York City then but until next time we're
going to try to get into the habit of
doing these live sessions again so until
next time please stay curious and stay
connected to the Deep questions of
reality so looking forward to joining
you either in New York soon or online in
the not too distant future until then
signing off from New York Brian
[Music]
Green
oh